it's great to welcome to the program
today Arian Foster who's a former NFL
football running back who retired in
2016 he's hosting now what with Arian
Foster I've been a guest on the show
excellent show
which we'll talk about Arian thanks for
being on I really appreciate it I
appreciate you man thank you for having
me
so let's just get out of the way because
it's coming up Super Bowl on Sunday it's
become almost an annual tradition here
in New England and not winning it by the
way just participating is this a
particular is this a special football
team or teams with Bill Belichick and
Tom Brady like is this really a unique
thing or is it yeah it's a good team but
it's not that that's special now they're
definitely a dynasty I would lean more
towards Tom Brady being the catalyst as
two wives so they're so impressive but
not to take anything I think he's really
good at what he does but I think in
order to win in this league you have to
have a great quarterback and I think Tom
Brady probably one of the best ever
what's your view at someone who was in
the league about all of this stuff that
like surrounds NFL football from a
cultural standpoint so like as some
examples of course we have the entire
national anthem protest issue which you
and I talked about when I was on your
program right the Super Bowl advertising
where a few years ago there was
controversy over a commercial that is it
might be anti-abortion but maybe it's
not it's not really clear this year a
cannabis legalization commercial was
rejected by the Super Bowl because it's
too controversial do these controversies
get to the players or is it basically
just you guys are playing football I
think there you have to kind of judge it
by an individual case by case scenario I
think that the the national anthem
protest I think that affected everybody
in NFL and everybody outside and it was
the most politically infused sports
situation I think since probably the the
protests at the Olympics in 1968 I
wasn't around for that but I
it'd be interesting if it was less
potent than that
because it was just the age of social
media and everything and kind of made
people choose sides but as far as the
the cannabis woman I think that's Anna
hillarious hypocrisy but I think for the
most part I think the players get too
much involved in into the into those
aspects of it especially at that time
and if you're in fear of the Super Bowl
you probably turn off everything and
just focus on the game because there's
so much hype surrounding it but I think
it's it's kind of who we are right it's
where an advert we're at an advertising
Society it's what it's all about
marketing advertising and the Super Bowl
is the most watched event in the world I
think so it makes sense that people are
gonna put their political ideologies and
try to infuse them with some kind of
marketing so when the the national
anthem stuff was more heated and the
president was commenting about it and
all of that was going on do you have a
sense of whether the players were
putting aside their personal political
beliefs like whether they were Democrats
or Republicans left or right wing and
sort of coming to the defense of the
speech of players in the NFL or do you
feel like it was it was along party
lines politically I can only speak for
my personal experience
I was one of the players that note was
cap on the first day the game won and so
there was a few of us that did and from
my vantage point it was a handful of
guys that were that I think really
understood what was I don't say at stake
but there was a few variables involved
right there's a free speech issue and
then there was a political issue with
police brutality and the way police
officers are being held accountable for
their actions and I think a handful of
guys really understood that but I think
what it what it did was it I think it
was really divisive in the way that it
and the president played an integral
part in in facilitating this the the lie
of you either page
or unpatriotic and what patriotic being
peeing and patriot even means so I think
that the the the players involved in the
protest I would hope so they all did
their due diligence and understood what
they were doing but from my vantage
point for the most part I think it was
it was it was very divisive do you know
of any players obviously this would just
be anecdotal but do you know of any
players who had the desire to support
Colin Kaepernick but didn't because they
were afraid of a backlash either from
the public or from owners or even from
the President himself oh yeah a bunch
actually yeah I think that was yeah it
was probably more the case nice
especially people of color in the in the
league which makes up the majority of
the league you know I got some guys
would like you I got family in the
military and we had a long talks of like
it has nothing to do with that but a lot
of guys like you I want to but I guess
it's not I can't like I can't do that I
don't love guys what I found was mmm I
feel like it you you can pretty much do
anything if you can intellectually
defend yourself right a lot of guys just
didn't want that pressure because it
gets into a deeply rooted history
historicity of this nation and what how
how its foundations is racist and that
is it's a daunting task to sit there in
front of the media who these people and
their their job is to get a clickbait
story that's their job and they're just
kind of poking and prodding you for a
headline and you're sitting here trying
to defend yourself and that's not what
that's not your lane that's not what you
do you're here to play football not make
a political statement I think that's
that's where a lot of guys fellows like
it I'm with it I feel understand what
you guys are saying right black I can't
I can't do it does is there a difference
I hesitate to use the term caste system
because like it's so politically uh it's
it's a tinderbox to use that term but is
are there sort of like tears within the
NFL where if you're in the top echelon
of superstar players you can get away
with more in terms of your activism or
what you do versus if you are a player
who is not as well known
anyways offensive or defensive line for
it for example and is not like a
celebrity player are there those tears
in terms of who can get away with more
absolutely there's a hierarchy no
question about it um I noticed it well I
was I'm kind of like walking proof of it
like I entered the league when I entered
the league I was an undrafted free agent
and then my rookie year after my rookie
year I led the NFL in rushing so like
the night and day difference of what I
could say or what I couldn't say right
they'll put up with a lot more with
somebody who's producing for them where
is that like I mean if you look at the
the Kaepernick situation right there's
no way there's no reason he should not
be in the NFL like no NFL player that
understands the game would at least
admit say okay he's at least a backup
right but the the the whirlwind
surrounding him nobody wants to take a
chance on that nobody wants to have that
in their locker room so like it's it's
about it's it's about the the storm that
that you would create so if you're
kneeling and you're said I was a
four-time Pro Bowler right so if I nail
mmm-hmm I'm more one of the faces of the
organization so I can I can defend
myself I can have a little bit more of a
platform and I have a little bit more of
a fan base that will probably agree with
the things that I say and if you're
lower on the hierarchy if your guy
displays special teams they don't want
that distraction that's that's what they
are they always say we don't want the
distraction which is it's [ __ ] but
it seems like that is not unique to the
NFL I mean we've seen in the NBA for
example and LeBron James becoming more
and more politically outspoken and
making taking more and more firm
positions as a superstar in the league
it seems like that that also exists in
other leagues I don't know if you have
any insight into that but that seems to
be my sense yeah I think it's just it's
just business I think I think when you
look at just a hierarchy of any business
if you have a top producing salesman at
your firm
he has a little more leniency behavior
wise than anybody else because you don't
want to lose that production because of
a little bit of behavior it's it's it's
always been like that
not just with political issues but if
you look at like saying a guy gets a DUI
say a guy gets in trouble with the law
something of that sort a guy has a
longer leash so they like to say a
couple of the things I want to talk to
you about that I think my audience would
find really interesting you were raised
Muslim but you know since I don't know
if the right term is you've you've
renounced your religion or you've become
an atheist or an agnostic or whatever
can you talk a little bit about I mean
first of all when you say you were
raised Muslim how how observant and then
what caused you to move away from that
right so uh my father was an FOI so I
was raised around like the Minister
Farrakhan kind of Muslims so what a
question Muslims not necessarily the
traditional Shiite or Sunni or something
like that yeah so they have they have a
certain way that they're a little bit
more politically aware as far as making
sure that their followers understand the
historicity of race in America and
things of that nature so I was raised in
that so I used to pray five times a day
to the east
my father was what the one thing that I
am appreciative of about it was that
they were really like I said they were
really politically aware but they also
made sure that you understood the Bible
you had to understand the Bible you had
to understand the Quran you had to
understand all aspects of religion
especially the Abrahamic prophets or
what they call the prophets so you you
had to have a basic understanding of all
of those things like jovis witnesses
used to knock on the door and my dad
used to invite him in we step to our
conversation it's like that's the kind
of household I grew up in Wow yeah and
so as I'm growing up in the world
what kind of made me stray away from it
was just inconsistencies I saw
the teachings inconsistent yes I saw
with the the people and when I was
younger I kinda just attributed to oh
they're all human beings and and were
foul in fact we're not they're not
infallible but as I grew I started to
question the actual doctrines right and
just the what they like to call the
problem of evil and philosophy things
like that and things like faith like why
is faith a good thing I started to
really question the foundation of what I
thought I believed and the more and more
question did the more and more I found
the answers or lack thereof or I found
people who were like-minded that weren't
necessarily condemning or shunning the
thoughts of that I was having and so and
so my parents never really did they were
always like find your own way this is
we're giving you a foundation and that's
one thing I love love them for too and
so it was it's night when I told him I
was atheist they were like yeah we kind
of figured they don't really care
they're just like you'll find your way
and was your so I guess now you you went
you found your atheism through Islam but
do you now think that it's just Islam
that is not for you or do you think that
this is it's all religions period oh no
it's all religions because I went
through it was like okay well what is
what is Christianity like so you know I
went to went to some Christian churches
went to some Catholic group around a lot
of Catholics and so I I dabbled I was
like okay now I was finding myself and
then I didn't go straight from Islam to
atheism
I went from Islam to let me try
Christianity let me try Catholicism to
you know you know they're all kind of
saying the same thing right so maybe
they're all just saying the same thing
and they're just getting the the words
just mixed up and so I was like okay I'm
agnostic as far as I believe there's
there's a higher power but there's no
way I could prove it I don't but you
know I still I still pray things of that
nature and then I reach a certain point
in my maybe early to mid-20s where I was
like this is starting to not make any
sense either just logically
did that these conversations come up
with your teammates and was it unusual
to have a non-religious teammate in the
NFL yeah it came up a lot really yeah
for some reason
football is is very much in a woven with
religion especially Christianity yeah
it's in the south and so I went to
college in the University of Tennessee
and there's a story I always like to
tell is they used to make us go to
church on Sundays sometimes like when
for like team camaraderie and this is
kind of like in the height of my I'm not
really feeling this anymore
and I used to go just out of respect you
know just just to go and so one day we
the he roused up all the team on the bus
and I was like I'm gonna go today and
they're like no you have to go my god I
don't have to do anything and they're
like oh you have to go this is and then
the coach pulls me in our office like
why don't you wanna go like I just don't
believe like like y'all believe and so
this doesn't do anything for me and he's
like well it's more about the team I was
like well if y'all go on a swimming trip
or something like that I'm there but
this is this is just not for me anymore
and they kind of look at you sideways
because it's not normal right a lot of a
lot of guys when I first came to the
University I see like some of my best
friends actually now to this day I
remember the first time we had it like a
team whack conversation because you're
meeting kids from you're 18 years old
you're meeting kids from you know I came
out of San Diego California grew up in
Albuquerque
they're from Tennessee Atlanta Florida
like you're just meeting kids that you
had never experienced before it was and
this is before the internet was really a
thing and so you're just exchanging
ideas ideologies and they figured out
that I didn't believe that Jesus was the
savior of man and one of my best friends
today he goes you don't believe in Jesus
you know you're going to hell right and
I was like that's why and so those kind
of conversations kicked off all the time
and so I was always kind of like on the
defense and I used to be a little bit
more aggressive with it like really
challenged their beliefs like trying to
corner me like cornermen illogical
pickle but as I grew it was more you
just kind of you can't like that's my
stepfather as you can't box with God
to shorten and and even in the NFL it
was still something that it wasn't just
in college that this was a thing it was
more inquiry in the NFL than it was in
college and college it was more like
they were trying to convert me and in
the NFL it was more like how did you get
this way like what happened to you and
like they were I remember they would
have like talk they'd be talking about
God or whatever the case might be and
then that for some reason that always
pulled me in Aaron come here man come on
let me I let you quit and so it was
always I was always like the the
spokesman for the non-believers never
come up where you would say hey hey guys
if God did exist do we really think he
would be picking winners in the NFL like
was that ever a conversation it was one
of my main points because like I said
footballs always infused with religion
right so like I know that our Father
prayer by heart because I'm saying it
since I was seven years old which is
wild before every game from Little
League football to the NFL
they say that our Father prayer and then
FL there they go to a separate place
because they respect people's beliefs a
little more but it was one of my like
what we used to bother me when a lot was
when guys get on TV after they win a
game like man ought to once want to
thank God I'm like do you really think
he had anything to do with it and if
you're thanking her for your health I
that that makes sense but like I
couldn't have done it without God I'm
like that just does likely that it's so
inconsistent
because they're the other team has the
same guy I guess you just prayed hard I
did he never made any sense to me and I
was kind of one of my points I always
threw at them and what I what I found
out was you like you said you can't box
with God because it's in its invisible
thing so I'll they all they have to
throw that way you just have to have
faith and that it just it just I can't I
can't have that with Arian Foster his
premium now what with Arian Foster is on
YouTube where I watch it also on iTunes
and a bunch of other places too right
yes it's pretty much on all podcast
platforms all right check it out we'll
link to it in the description to the
YouTube video Arian really appreciate
you talking to me today pleasures all
mine man